mais revenons-en maintenant au grand
événement sportif de la journée
la finale de la coupe de france de
football qui a commencé au parc des
princes il ya près d'une demi heure en
présence du président mitterrand jacques
chirac et de nombreuses personnalités
ce sont les deux clubs les plus
populaires qui s'affrontent
saint-etienne et paris saint germain
pour les parisiens c'est une grande
première qui a lieu de surcroît sur leur
pelouse du parc pour les stéphanois
c'est peut être l'occasion de faire un
doublé puisqu'ils ont déjà soufflé à
monaco le titre de champion de france
alors en toute dernière minute où en
est-on gens ma mère est bien après une
demi-heure de jeu entre le paris
saint-germain donc en blanc sur votre
écran et saint-etienne en vert
traditionnellement 0 à 0 toujours dans
cette 65e finale de la coupe de france
un match tendu mais un match correct de
part et d'autre les meilleures actions
sont pourtant à mettre à l'actif depuis
ce début de rencontre au à l'actif des
parisiens notamment sur un tir très
puissant à bout portant de rocheteau qui
a été bloquée in extremis par castaneda
ce match vous le disiez est important
pour les parisiens
car s'il remportait cette finale et bien
il aurait le droit de disputer la saison
prochaine une coupe d'europe c'est je le
rappelle la première finale disputée ce
soir par les parisiens c'est un club
jeune il a été créé en 74 par daniel
hechter puis repris aujourd'hui par le
président borelli pour les stéphanois se
serait un titre qui leur manque puisque
celui de champion de france
laura était souple et lors de la
dernière journée du championnat par
monaco mais les stéphanois eux sont
d'ores et déjà assurés de jouer une
coupe d'europe la saison prochaine
que dire d'autre que ce soir platini est
très marqué et on le comprend
et puis il y a tout de même un atout et
pour conclure pour ces parisiens c'est
qu'il n'a jamais perdu en championnat
sur leur pelouse face à saint-etienne
oui dieu merci j'en au maire a rectifié
mon propos c'est bien sûr monaco qui est
champion de france